[Applause]
okay we'll open the meeting it is
just past five o'clock two minutes past
five
and we'll ask for apologies please
any conflicts of interest
no conflicts of interest so we'll move
on to item three
or just before then the meeting is being
recorded the pandemic
i've just been told the pandemic has
been
extended um 23rd of december 23rd
december so this will be
on live on
youtube youtube tomorrow morning
uh moving on to item three and ask don
and mark to come up to the table please
thank you thank you
we're here to present just one report
and
a relatively procedural type report
which
is really just trying to tidy up an
element which you've already adopted to
reference and the result
of the request
for attendees to be on the
on the working group resulted in an
initially of eight coming back so
rather than go through a process of
trying to
choose out of that uh eight who shall be
the five
which we felt was fairly fraught with
difficulties and the
five was always a relatively uh
arbitrary number
i'm just trying to keep things more we
feel really comfortable with
eight representatives and felt that was
an easier path to go down
so the main item here is to
change that however in addition
we as staff have taken the opportunity
to tidy up two or three other things in
terms of reference which are obviously
up for your debate and you can choose
whether to
include those or not in your
recommendations
and lastly there is the chair the
appointment of a chair
we at the time of writing this report
that we didn't have
um yet enough information about who
could be chair we as staff
had sought um two
other options other than yourself it was
only this morning that one of those came
back and said they didn't
feel that they would be suitable
or they didn't want the disposition and
so we
really had one suggestion for you at the
stage
other than yourself so the suggestion we
would like to put forward
as a chair is sandra james who
many of you will be aware of was a staff
member
10 years or so ago and has since been
doing
quite a range of different activities
around the
city and the district and is well versed
in this type of
activity and is available and willing to
assist
um they are
i think the only ones we have any
feedback from at mama yes
um so sandra was very keen to be
involved
i spoke to because today she thought
she would be a little bit too close to
some people
uh involved and also felt that it could
be
um a rather robust discussion that she
said she wasn't
haven't been involved in recent sharing
and things like that another person that
i've tried to get a response from
is um tammy martin so our corpse team
so that she's done some work in that
space in the past i'm
i apologize that's not supposed to
happen
um very much just to add some additional
comment to
the uh the resident group it's a little
bit of a moving target with the numbers
so one person today
has um suggested they'd like to pull out
of that route
but yesterday another resident um
suggested the diet to be involved
so the number would still potentially be
aids but the additional resident
is not on piracy street or victory
street they're
on fuller street so they're literally
just around the corner opposite the
church
the person's name is paul croucher city
is a long-standing resident
um
so far the residents i guess that have
said put their name for they haven't
indicated if they're against
all four which is which is i guess
appropriate
but this was said
um but because he's not on the street i
don't know if that has an
impact on the board's view and that he
could be probably a
former community representative field
but it's up to consideration and i've
said that i've been involved tomorrow
there's isn't it three amenities and one
of them on career street
one's on the corner
[Applause]
so have you got any further pass our
presentation and we had anything
thank you any questions from the board
is
because she wants to know when this was
taking place and i said the numbers have
increased to eight and she said look at
the numbers of ages i don't really need
to build it she was just a bit concerned
that there wasn't going to be enough
representation
in the initial conservation so
thank you thank
thanks mark you did you have any other
applications after the cut-off
point you know i mean so just to step in
things
so do you think it's appropriate to
appoint people after you
i guess this is what coming to the board
with um
suggesting this this person um because
they wasn't part of the
um literature that went out to the
street and outside of the scope of that
and they hadn't received any information
so i think they've seen it on a facebook
page and so suggested through the
facebook
portal they'd be interested to be part
of it so yeah i
i guess i'm not sure if that's
appropriate because it's outside of the
scope of the time
and they're not on the street but they
bring probably more of a community here
rather than a street view
i think procedurally we would suggest
that
if you were wanting to be procedurally
strong and robust
in your decision making that would
probably be best to decline this
application
was after the time that we sought any
years ahead of the street
so it does depend uh the reasons for
allowing it would be to increase
representation and we
we're really in a working party working
group
type it's not a vote-taking exercise
uh and so the reasons for including it
would be to ensure that
you know a wide range of views we're at
the table
um but we have no firm view about which
way
you would like to go on this uh so
that's just a little bit of guidance
that i feel
um which way you may vote for me
um representation from the cycle
lot one or two can you give us any more
info who they represent and how many
what weight they bring to the table and
so we've got
um one person that's recommended to us
from the healthcare recycling club
they're actually out of town at the
moment and so i haven't been able to
talk to them but at this stage we're
just looking at one representative from
the north carolina cycling we felt that
they probably would bring
their representation from a mortgage
everywhere cycling
have we not got anyone local that we can
approach mark
try and tease out some cyclists and find
if we wanted
you know two representatives we talked
about one or two
we we felt it best to approach the
organization
the organisation has recommended this
person
so rather than us shoulder handling
cyclists
with shoulder techniques
thank you madam chair um just a couple
things in terms of the right hearing
info i see that that could have a lot of
influence in terms of whether or not
these cyclists
will be found will industry or go down
victory
etc has there been any decisions made
with regatta
with regard to that and secondly in
terms of the
discussions that the applications will
have
back with the residents is there any
discussions as to how that's going to
work
with regard to the former if the outcome
at the end of this process is that the
board decides to
have a cycle layer on piracy street then
there would be very clear
way finding signage at the corner of the
career
and williams which would tend to lead
people
at the right intersections they will be
signed to lead people along
if the board chooses to not endorse
karaki as uh as a cycleway
then i think as referred to at an
earlier meeting we would probably look
to putting
uh some sort of just directional i
wouldn't call it
information signage at that point which
would say you are here
uh the bridge is over here and here are
some streets and people would make
their own decisions on that basis
with regard to the second point we have
had quite a lot of thought about how
this could work and
it's not part of your resolution as such
but we're happy to share
our initial reports we're thinking that
we will hold two workshops in a row
the first one is probably a little bit
of a scene setting up
getting things on the table and then off
the table
as well as having some initial coffee as
well as
setting the ground rules about how these
things will apply and also beginning
some conversation hopefully about
options
the second one which would be a week
later would go into more detail about
the issues that people are facing and
the
options to to mitigate that what we
would hope for at the end of the second
one
is a scheme plan
that the group was happy to consult on
i'm not saying they are happy with the
plan
because they still may object to it but
they agree
that it represents something that we can
then take to the residence
we then have a two-week process for the
residents
where we would be sending out plans
surveyed a survey form
and a in an invitation
to partake in and we're thinking things
like street corner meetings
as well as doorstep meetings so people
can ask
to meet with us the street corner
meetings we're thinking we would have
three or four or five in an afternoon at
one o'clock
two o'clock three o'clock and we'd be at
the corner of hugh and peraki and then
we'd go to the corner of fuller and
karaki or whatever it might be we
haven't thought through that detail but
we would have a number of
smaller meetings rather than a
big meeting we had initially thought
about a drop-in
meeting like a drop-in session and i
think it'll depend a little bit on the
feedback we're getting we'll think about
that a little bit more
in conjunction with the working party
about whether that is necessary
after we've done that then the survey
forms will come back we've had quite a
bit of discussion about the nature of
those survey forms
we would like them to give as much
information as possible rather than just
a yes
no answer but we probably appreciate
that people will want to say a yes no
answer somewhere on the forum
so we'll be seeking as much information
to give you guidance
as we can on that we will then collate
that information
and have another workshop with the
working group
to discuss what the community has said
and then at that point we would prepare
a report for you
pulling together the various sources of
information including
the minutes and the notes and the
outcomes from the working group
the survey and and our own review and
our own recommendation as well
for the full part of that at which time
you would make your decision and we're
planning on that being
at your december meeting when i say you
would make your decision
you would make your recommendation to
the council
uh council for unr we're just thinking
in december there's not much opportunity
for
further meetings to endorse that um
given that you're in the middle of
december but we would just
think about that and work through that
with the likes of the governance team to
make sure we had an appropriate
response time ideally the outcome of all
of this will be a decision
before christmas one way or the other
so that we can either begin the next
stage of designing the works and
paraguay
or finding where we're gonna and
reallocating the money and
designing that works all with the
intentions as we all know if it's not
spent by the end of june it
disappears so i hope that gives a
breakdown of
our current thinking isn't in your
recommendations but we do
would still retain the flexibility of
how that all works
um don i'm looking at the working group
um terms of reference and item number
eight
delegation and you've quite clearly said
pbsc wg has no delegated authority
but i think it's important to add any
recommendations add to the ktcp
your thoughts yes that is our intention
yeah so it was just to ensure that it
was very clear everybody got no decision
making entity
[Applause]
and this meeting is managed of course
and they'll
and those minutes will be distributed to
uh
hypocritically we commune toward that so
that everybody knows what's going on
um very different sorry just clarify
that point they will be minuted but as
you will have also noted in
the terms of we are ensuring we're we're
trying to make sure
and and you'll see the chatham house
rules yes
it won't be allocated
from my point of view i'd like to see
more cycling
advocates as in a definite two
rather than just one your thoughts on
that
we release the time frames now mark
has come to me in the last couple of
days and expressed a bit of a concern
about our original time frame now that
we're sort of squeezing things up with
further meetings and this meeting
so our time frame now probably does
allow that
our first of our workshop meetings is
their second option
about the 27th so that's two or three
weeks away so
with that extra week i think we do have
the opportunity to
keep looking for that representative and
and they're very happy to take that
advice
and my other question to you is paul
dallas
is he representing the residence and the
um fire brigade no no he'll just be
represented
[Applause]
management that so he put his name
forward saying he was wanting to be
represented before the game of asking
for confirmation from the fire service
rather than just his words yes yeah
and my other question is
and i think he might have answered it
earlier um do you have anyone that's
for the actual cycleway on this
team of eight um i haven't asked that
question
i'm thinking that you probably haven't
but i would have thought that would have
been quite important
we we thought carefully about
how people get appointed onto here and
we felt
that it was inappropriate for us
or for you frankly i guess to say
you can because you hold this view and
you can't be because you hold that view
so we just invited the whole street we
didn't ask on what their views are and
in a way we'll take what we get uh
and and work with those
we're very hopeful
that there will be people amongst that
group
who uh are willing to listen and discuss
and be open about
the conversation and don't come in with
toothpicks to mind
that we can make some good progress okay
cool
any more questions ali can i ask
um i'm pretty unhappy about staff being
removed from the committee can i ask
how you envisage that will work in a
supportive role
actually on the around the table on the
day
how do you embrace that
i visit you similar i guess to any
workshop or briefing we have with you
normally we are not there as equal
partners
and if i'm being totally honest even if
we are named as equal partners
some are more equal than others and
we've we've always taken that
uh approach so a staff member being part
of a working group i think
places that staff member in a bit of an
ambitious decision we are there to
assist and advise help facilitate help
give good information make sure people
are whatever but we're
so i think that was on reflection
afterwards i felt it was an
error to put us on there in the first
place
again this is your resolution to
change or amend or whatever that's
that's our recommendation to you is that
we shouldn't be on it
uh and i think that would probably sarah
would support that from a government's
perspective
your
just a quick question while it doesn't
come here in terms of reference
i assume the council will provide the
secretarial support
to the working party yes yes okay thank
you
thank you that is a good point better
cheer what i'm talking to you about is
happening unfortunately that this is our
third attempt and
i'm
you just just informed us that i i was
hoping and i had my fingers crossed that
the first meeting might have been
leading up to the to the week of that
17th
we'll be honest we will be on stuart
island after the changes for the
environment
um on the 22nd now um
what i'd love to be there this is this
this has got to work and it's going to
flow
it's going to be consistent you know i
think that it would be unfair for me to
say
just just change things for me i i'm
quite happy to actually
step aside but if i have to um
the dates we're considering at the
moment
mark's been getting over backwards to
try and make things work
um we've now realized of course that the
first monday that we were anticipating
actually clashes with the cowboy
community board meeting and we feel it's
not appropriate that we take two of your
members away for a
working group so we would probably shift
that to that
thursday we're thinking and then the
following one of course is actually
labor day and we hold it on that day so
we would shift that day as well
the other issue mark has been facing
with is we have been
working very hard to try and have
this working group meet in the church
because it
it is more we felt it was more
home ground so to speak for the
residents
they have relatively restricted
time frames that are available and as
well as relatively restricted
facilities as we saw the other night
we're now thinking we'll probably
inquire with enc and see about a sphere
room there and so we've probably got a
little bit of an iterative process to go
through here before we find
dates and a place that actually
match together but it is at the moment
we we're thinking it'll be that thursday
though
if you were missing for one day one of
the workshop days
[Music]
you know
[Applause]
any further questions well
moving on to the recommendation
anyone like to move a b
and c
is there any discussion around the chair
before we move these this and mark and
don has suggested santa james
who i would certainly endorse as a very
good secret motion
well you can have a discussion i assume
and then bring it in
put them separately
[Applause]
we can hear the discussion well i'll
move as a separate
as a separate we appoint sandra james as
chair of the working group the second to
place
they're always in favour
[Applause]
and i would um
everything would that actually alter the
actual terms of reference
you're not locked into
[Applause]
is you could put five to ten in the
little brackets
under number two and that allows
exactly the point that we'll keep it
up tonight i would keep it up
[Applause]
and for clarity one might say this is a
bit of a moving feast with regard to the
people coming and going we would
anticipate that as of today that is not
a move infested it's finalised there are
no more applications no more requests
your vote today will not lock it
thank you so
just before we move that everybody happy
with two people from the same family
[Applause]
maybe there are opposing sides
yep
is
okay recommendation a and b
somebody right to move that please as it
stands
or you can amend
[Applause]
up
it wouldn't be unreasonable for the
working party once it's formed
to if there was somebody else who was
um a resident and to join it but that
would have to be his decision
of the whole working group and once it
was formed
and i would like to see two community
board members there
so somebody available that could stand
in for john if he's not there
and regardless of who that is yes
except them chair that at the previous
meeting we resolved
to appoint john maybe you could add
another
the whole thing this is a challenge but
i'm i'm in favor of somebody
so i think if we bring in another
a b we've done c and d
two community boards john and
and martin um with another being edited
um being able to
yeah well you can if you want to yes
and the community will chair if um
john's
well one of them is not available
have you written that yeah
okay so we're receiving a
and b and d
is and just noting um
item four on the terms of reference
would be amended to
specify senator
[Music]
[Applause]
um just the addition that was spoken
about
of any recommendations to the kaikouri
to ohio community board and on 12
just an addition there of the notes
circulated
to the community board
[Applause]
where it says well ideally rich
consensus that will form a
recommendation to the ktcb
and also nine point five yeah this few
things are being replaced
[Applause]
yep
okay we're back to the recommendation
a b and d okay
that the chairperson of the cargo to
evie community board
shall serve as alternate if the
nominated
representative of the cab which we
required could not attend
the piracy and victory
street cycle working group meetings do
we have someone move that please
also have to move those benefits to you
you'll move those babies
second up
rent which i expect that martin
yeah just very briefly i just want to
say that i think we've talked about this
before
while there have been issues with the
residents of bratislava victory street
as we implement our whole cycling and
walking strategy
i'm hoping that this will be a template
for how we might
deal with other strengths because you
know it's unheard of all that
there's going to be a difference of
opinion as to the suitability of the
other resident strength for these sort
of sites so
i just would like to think we've got to
really persevere with this and
and try and make it work because we'll
set a template for how we operate
in the future i would
like to hear what you've just seen and
also thank
dom and mark and the team and the work
that you've done
and it's would love to see this money
spending card for you and make sure that
the streets that are going to be
cycleways
are going to be safe so thank you
um thank you madam chair yeah i'll
support the the motions i've
i've got two uh two misgivings one is
the size of the thing
um you know to me 17 people isn't a work
working group it's
a talk fest good luck sandra trying to
keep that little lot
in line especially as quite a few of
them will have very little knowledge of
of committee procedure probably and i'm
also
reiterating what i said before i'm i'm
opposed to the
um our engine our staff not being on the
committee
i i find that really strange a lot of
the things you're going to have to fight
your way through to come to a
to a compromise with everybody are going
to be very technical
and to remove the roading and traffic
engineers
i find that you know quite quite strange
we
councillors will tell you how many times
we get cold round the table up there
we're not roading engineers
we're not traffic engineers there's a
risk we're going to have 17 traffic
engineers
and the traffic engineers are on the
committee which i
say i find that almost bizarre but so
i appreciate the comment just
clarification though
you will be both of you will be there
all the time can i just
expand on that and i just i just i
understand exactly where you're coming
from
but um
yeah in a practical sense are they going
to be cutting into the conversation
or are you going to sit there and debate
some something
for 10 minutes and then ask don or mark
can we do this and they'll say no
because that won't get past the safety
order no i'll bug it so we'll go back
and
i don't understand how it's going to
work to be up to sandra
to manage that it's effectively just
not having that voting right round the
table when you're actually coming to
make some sort of consensus
recommendation
their expertise will come through the
reports they'll come to the board and
the council on june 4.
so what sandra is going to be managing
as a working
[Music]
how residents would be appointed to the
group
and i just wondered if we fall into the
same trend today because it doesn't
actually
say who the residents are going to be in
the
resolution if you've
[Applause]
you can resolve it formally and
members who were selected
[Applause]
the criteria previously in eggs out of
time
okay an alternative addition you could
be
to say that does the amended
which will have the effect of increasing
the number of
resident
i'm just sort of thinking you could word
it so that the same residents will be
appointed
all residents who apply prior to will be
[Applause]
residence he felt that it might
not be it might be too overwhelming for
people who have put their name forward
to suddenly have their name
all the way up and down the street even
though people can find that name
if yes but you've put it in the public
report
so they're already named exactly so you
may as well name them in the in the
recommendation
it's just put it it's just bringing it
up another level i guess
in terms exposing
them whereas as we pointed out it's
more in the background of the report at
the moment
and we're aware that everybody will
probably notice that we're just not
going to be the ones that
for instance put those eight names it
will send them names
in a letter to every resident that's our
feeling
so we can't include um paul
because there are many others that
actually apply for the situation as well
in time in time yeah but he was late so
we couldn't
okay so back to the recommendation
a b d and
e with the names included
the seven names included
all referenced
[Applause]
so that would be all those seven names
with the exclusion of
rachel
[Applause]
if we've got someone that would like to
move should we cover that by
closing it
yep
[Applause]
well we shouldn't have to because it
should be written somewhere
eventually that's referred to in there
those names are referred to in the
report yeah
subsequent information says that one of
them doesn't so i don't
think there is a problem with item e
simply being those seven ones
absolutely
so we can change that represent of
representations update that'll be right
okay a b and d a b and d
sorry do we have b
b
have we got some move up yeah
and
the motion has been moved almost in
favor
those ants
thank you don and mark